so this is going to be video class notes
for a lake worth florida workshop
we started out talking about basic
framing ideas and getting into some in
swings and the not coleman 3d so
the concept of framing is that your poi
planes frame your body
conversely your body can also frame your
poi plane so here i am
both things are framing my body this is
normally sort of how we operate with
macro
moves big boy moves but we can also of
course like with the buzz
frame or koi in a variety of ways but
then there's also a lot of really
interesting ways that you can move
in and out of said frames
and inversions and other things are all
part of that but we played with
just getting used to how you can in
swinging in and out of this buzzsaw
frame in between your arms
by taking the poi and flipping the wrist
back and forth from the home side into
the buzzsaw frame
and then also by pushing and pulling
over and under the poi across the other
arm to get outside of that frame
that pushing and pulling might feel a
little more like what happens when you
thread the needle
from the needle involves pushing and
pulling no wrist flipping
this stuff although it's in wheel plane
and not a wall plane sort of thing
it's still that same sort of pushing and
pulling without wrist flipping
so to get into the knot coleman 3 really
simple way to do it is to start out one
hand over the other just dangling them
take the one on the bottom bring it up
through the arm
and flip it over the top and just sort
of repeat that a couple times
you're comfortable with that spin the
boy
with arms crossed and see if you can
bring that point up through the center
put it on top and once you can repeat
that without
extra lockout loops then you'll be doing
enough pullman 3
which looks a lot like a 3d weave unless
you're looking at what the wrists are
doing
and the arms are doing there's no wrist
flipping
the poi is sort of coming up through the
bust off frame close to the armpits
and hopping over the top for the reverse
version it's all backwards you're
taking the arm on top down
and through you can repeat the same
steps to learn the reverse version
if you can do forwards in reverse
you can turn with them
and we also pointed out that this is a
really fun way
to get involved with crossers with a
crossover when you're not using an in
swing if you want to switch which arm is
on top you sort of have to
like come around and get there
or then maybe you actually have to weave
over here for a second to get that arm
back on top
but if you're comfortable within swings
you can just
throw one of those through the middle
all slick like
go back on your crosser
the other thing we brought up is head
leading and hand leading isolations
so one of the things that helps with
these sort of in-swing base moves is
if you can take your poi handle and drag
the boy head around your wrist my
hand and the handle is leading dragging
the poi head which is following
if it sort of isolates around the wrist
apply that to something like a nachoman
to get this sort of this fun sort of
effect
of course if you can drag the handle
around the wrist and the head follows
you can also play with isolating such
that the
head gets flicked around the head leads
and then your hand
chases and getting used to both of those
sort of movements
is really useful then when you're
framing these moves
if you're in wheel playing your arms are
out long creating this long
thin frame gives you a lot of space when
you move to wall plane
it's sort of squat it's flat your elbows
are out so it's very wide frame
so that you have space to have a poi in
between your arms there
and it's really useful to play with
moving
from sort of wheel plane with a long
frame
folding to a flat frame long plane or
long frame
flat frame getting used to that your
body has to move dynamically through
this while you're turning and playing
with the poi
when we were in the wall plane not only
were we doing some of the crosser things
we were also playing with this this
exercise where we
are dangling the poi and sort of just
flipping one over
right here in the wall plane flipping
one over in wall planes so that
we get used to this flat frame in front
of us and that very naturally can turn
into a butterfly
or throw the needle move with in swings
the simplest simplest simplest one is
from a
together time thread the needle that's a
two beat throughout the needle this is
an inward throttle needle every time
the hand draws back
under the other hand that's when you
would in swing
flipping your wrist in so this is taking
a move that normally only has pushing
and pulling and no wrist flipping and
we're
drawing back and adding a wrist flip
such that we're we're literally turning
our wrist in and it sounds like we're
drawing a circle
on our tummy notice the side to side
movement that's my arms moving back and
forth
elongating the frame so that i can more
comfortably flip through there we
covered a split time
3b thread the needle because i feel like
a lot of this
butterfly in swinging stuff is more
comfortable from that
you have more time you have three
rotations you have a whole
extra rotation on each side before you
have to do your next in swim
the keys to learning split time thread
the needles are that
because it's a split time move the poi
are meeting on
the horizon on the left and right so
there's a horizontal mirror line
rather than a vertical one and because
of that
we're taking and stacking the hands one
next to the other
and crossing over so see i'm putting my
hands next to each other
horizontally rather than stacking one on
top of the other
and taking turns crossing over and
stacking next to
and from there you can take the extra
rotations out
and learn split time through through the
needle and this is a nice one also
come because your hand is coming back
underneath
you swing up and in for any of these in
reverse
uh you just flip it upside down so
you're going to take the hand
that's coming back over the top and drop
it down
this brings up a another framing uh idea
so there's a moment when my poi is
swinging
right past my arm and my arm
and the poi create another frame
so that i can i can send my opposite poi
right through that little pocket that
frame
and that's what i'm looking for when i'm
doing this split time
three beat thread the needle in fact
where are the sticks
the poi are moving in split time
opposite direction
there's a moment when they're coming
together on the horizon
where this poi and this arm make that
pocket and i'm
sending the other one right through that
frame they come
all the way over here now there's a
frame on
on this other side and this poi has
dropped out of it
and they come all the way around again
and this one
comes through that frame again so
there's a whole bunch of aiming to get
the poi in between this frame that the
the other poi and arm
make and that gives you a real good
focus for like where and when to slip
your arms through
you